or just simply to run.
The first annual all-women-and-girls race for empowerment,
which is one of its kind in the region,
has just taken place only a few weeks ago,
with 4,512 women, including the first lady,
and this is only the beginning.
Thank you.
(Applause)
BMA has supported charities and volunteers
who have helped reshape Lebanon,
raising funds for their causes
and encouraging others to give.
The culture of giving and doing good has become contagious.
Stereotypes have been broken.
Change-makers and future leaders have been created.
I believe these are the building blocks for future peace.
BMA has become such a respected event in the region
that government officials in the region,
like Iraq, Egypt and Syria,
have asked the organization to help them structure a similar sporting event.
We are now one of the largest running events in the Middle East,
but most importantly,
it is a platform for hope and cooperation
in an ever-fragile and unstable part of the world.
From Boston to Beirut, we stand as one.
(Applause)
After 10 years in Lebanon,
from national marathons or from national events
to smaller regional races,
we've seen that people want to run for a better future.
After all, peacemaking is not a sprint.
It is more of a marathon.
Thank you.
(Applause)